From NPR, this is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Almost a century and a half ago, a young German philosopher named Herman Ebinghaus picked up a curious book at a used bookstore. It was called Elements of Psychophysics and it described how to gather data on invisible mental processes. The book gave Ebinghaus an idea. And he thinks about, okay, well, we all have this experience of learning information and forgetting information. How can I study that? Psychologist Ayanna Thomas. She says Epping House wanted to answer a big question. How does memory work?
来自NPR，这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。大约一个半世纪前，一位年轻的德国哲学家名叫赫尔曼·艾宾浩斯，在一家旧书店里拿起了一本奇怪的书。这本书叫做《心理物理学纲要》，它描述了如何收集无形心理过程的数据。这本书给了艾宾浩斯一个主意。他在想，好吧，我们都有学习信息和遗忘信息的经历。我该如何研究它呢？心理学家阿亚娜·托马斯说。她说艾宾浩斯想要回答一个宏大的问题。记忆是如何运作的？
He really wanted to understand to memory at its most basic core. How quickly can we learn? New information that we've never We really wanted to understand to memory at its most basic core. How quickly can we learn? New information that we've never been exposed to, and how quickly does that information degrade. This was the late 1800s. There was no protocol on how to run a psychology experiment. Most insights about memory came from philosophers and theologians.
他真的很想了解记忆最基础的核心。我们能以多快的速度学习？从未接触过的新信息，以及这些信息退化的速度有多快。那是19世纪末。当时还没有关于如何进行心理学实验的规范。关于记忆的大多数见解都来自于哲学家和神学家。
So Ebbinghaus came up with a plan. He would run an experiment on himself. First he needed something to memorize. He came up with the idea of nonsense syllables, three random letters strung together. He put them on some cards. So more than 2000 of these. Then he shuffled the cards, divided them into groups,
于是艾宾浩斯想出了一个计划。他要在自己身上做一个实验。首先，他需要一些可以背诵的东西。他想出了无意义音节的主意，即把三个随机字母串联在一起。他把它们写在一些卡片上。有两千多张这样的卡片。然后他把卡片洗匀，分成几组，
and set about learning them in a variety of controlled conditions. Sometimes, he read the cards aloud. Forcing himself to read them at the exact same rate in the same soft tone of voice, keeping time to a ticking metronome. He would read a group of cards aloud once, hide it, and then try to recite it from memory. Every time he made a mistake, he would stop, note it in his records, and start over.
并开始在各种受控条件下学习它们。有时，他会大声朗读卡片。强迫自己以完全相同的速度、相同的柔和声调朗读，并配合着滴答作响的节拍器节拍。他会大声朗读一组卡片一遍，把它们藏起来，然后试图凭记忆背诵出来。每次犯错，他就会停下来，在记录中记下错误，然后重新开始。
Like move, walk. He kept doing this, stopping and starting over, stopping and starting over, until he could recite a group of syllables perfectly. He repeated this process periodically to see how much he could remember 20 minutes later, an hour later, nine hours, a day, and so on. Stopping, starting over, stopping, starting over for more than six months.
比如移动、走路。他一直这样做，停下来重新开始，停下来重新开始，直到他能完美地背诵出一组音节。他定期重复这个过程，看看20分钟后、一小时后、九小时后、一天后等等，他能记住多少。停下来，重新开始，停下来，重新开始，持续了半年多。
The experiments were highly precise and monotonous and required a huge amount of self-discipline. His greatest enemy was boredom. Years later, Ebinghaus told a group of psychologists about the tedium of his more celebrated accomplishment. I shall not go into the agony that months on end of such study engendered in me. I attempted leg move, walk, dial, send, cap, move to the cardboard, move here, don't get. In retrospect, the magnitude of the task seems staggering to me. And you might ask why would anyone want to do that? Well, his motivation was he wanted to see what information was remembered, but also how much information was forgotten. This week on Hidden Brain, the science of memory from the early ideas of Epping House to the latest discoveries of modern psychologists. How do our minds hold on to the events of the past? What are the most common ways our memories fail us? Can we ever really know for sure that our memories are telling us the truth?
这些实验高度精确且单调乏味，需要极大的自律。他最大的敌人是无聊。多年后，艾宾浩斯向一群心理学家讲述了他那项更著名的成就所带来的乏味感。我不想去描述长达数月的这种研究所带给我的痛苦。我试图移动腿、走路、拨号、发送、盖帽子、把卡片移到纸板上、移到这里、没拿住。回想起来，这项任务的巨大规模让我感到震惊。你可能会问，为什么会有人想这么做呢？好吧，他的动机是想看看哪些信息被记住了，同时也有多少信息被忘记了。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们将探讨记忆的科学，从艾宾浩斯早期的想法到现代心理学家的最新发现。我们的心灵是如何留住过去发生的事件的？我们的记忆失灵最常见的方式有哪些？我们是否真的能确切地知道我们的记忆告诉我们的是真相？
How we remember, why we forget, and the simple lessons we can all learn to make our memories sharp and vivid. Herman Ebikhal's remember thousands of three-letter strings and then try to see how many he remembered the same day, the next week, the next year. He discovered something that many of us experienced. Over time, he started to forget things, but since he was running an experiment, it allowed him to actually measure how much he was forgetting and how quickly. It led him to discover something that is today called the forgetting curve. That forgetting curve, if you look at it, you see an exponential decline in what he can
我们如何记住，我们为什么会遗忘，以及我们所有人都可以从中吸取的简单教训，能让我们的记忆保持敏锐和生动。赫尔曼·艾宾浩斯记住了数千个三字母串，然后试着看他在同一天、第二周、第二年分别能记住多少。他发现了一个我们许多人都经历过的现象。随着时间的推移，他开始忘记事情，但由于他正在进行实验，这使他能够真正测量出他正在忘记多少以及忘记的速度有多快。这促使他发现了如今被称为遗忘曲线的规律。如果你看一下这条遗忘曲线，你会看到随着时间的推移，他所能
accurately remember as time passes. This again is Ayanna Thomas, a psychologist at Tufts University who studies memory. You see a really quick drop-off. So by the time you get out to a week and then a month, there's a lot of information that's been lost. But I also think what's really neat is, a month later, there's quite a bit of information that still has been retained. Hmm.
准确记住的内容呈指数级下降。再次说明，这是塔夫茨大学研究记忆的心理学家阿亚娜·托马斯。你会看到一个非常快速的下降。因此，到了一个星期甚至一个月的时候，已经有大量的信息丢失了。但我同时也认为很酷的一点是，一个月后，仍然保留了相当多的信息。嗯。
What I find really interesting about this story, Iana, is that it reveals two things that at some level feel intuitively true to us. All of us have this experience of remembering something and then finding a week later we can't remember what we remembered. And also realizing that if we try and relearn what it is that we have forgotten, it is quicker the second time around than the first. So at one level, he is telling us things that we all experience in our life. But was he also in some ways putting on the map, the idea, that you can actually study these things empirically, that there was a science to memory, that it was amenable to measurement
阿亚娜，我觉得这个故事真正有趣的地方在于，它揭示了在某种程度上对我们来说具有直观真实性的两件事。我们所有人都有这样的经历：记住了一些事情，然后一周后发现自己记不起当时记住的是什么了。并且还意识到，如果我们试图重新学习我们已经忘记的东西，第二次会比第一次更快。因此，在某种程度上，他在讲述我们所有人在生活中都经历过的事情。但他在某种程度上是否也将这样一个理念摆在了台面上：你实际上可以用经验主义的方法来研究这些事情，记忆是有科学性的，它是可以被测量
and to precision? Indeed, he was the first to bring this into a laboratory where he has a hypothesis about how memory is going to operate. And he operationalizes the construct of memory. So I think about memory as a really broad construct, a really broad term. And that term can encompass so many different things. Right now, I'm using memory to communicate with you, right?
和精确化的？的确，他是第一个将这一点带入实验室的人，他对记忆将如何运作有一个假设。他将记忆这个构念操作化了。因此，我认为记忆是一个非常广泛的构念，一个非常广泛的术语。这个术语可以涵盖如此多的不同事物。此刻，我正在使用记忆来与你沟通，对吧？
I'm bringing things up from my long-term memory, and I'm using my working memory to communicate that information. But that's not how Ebbinghaus operationalized it. So he thinks about, okay, well, we all have this experience of learning information and forgetting information. How can I study that?
我正在从我的长期记忆中提取信息，我正在使用我的工作记忆来传达这些信息。但这并不是艾宾浩斯将其实施操作化的方式。因此，他在思考，好吧，我们都有学习信息和遗忘信息的经历。我该如何研究它？
And in order to study memory, and what Eminghouse introduced us to is that we have to figure out what our construct is, we have to define that construct, and then we have to develop tasks that are appropriate to the definition of that construct. You can think about memory in a whole host of different ways. I know how to write a bike, but I can't tell you exactly how to do it.
为了研究记忆，而艾宾浩斯向我们介绍的是，我们必须弄清楚我们的构念是什么，我们必须定义该构念，然后我们必须开发与该构念的定义相匹配的任务。你可以用各种不同的方式来思考记忆。我知道如何骑自行车，但我无法确切地告诉你该怎么做。
I just know how to do it. That's still an element of memory, and not the one that Ebing House was studying. After Herman Ebing House, other researchers came along and said, okay, we can study memory systematically. Through careful observation and measurement, we can see how memory works and when it fails. In the 1930s, Frederick Bartlett set up an experiment that revealed a very interesting aspect of memory.
我只是知道怎么做。这仍然是记忆的一个要素，但不是艾宾浩斯正在研究的那一个。在赫尔曼·艾宾浩斯之后，其他研究人员出现了，他们说，好吧，我们可以系统地研究记忆。通过仔细的观察和测量，我们可以看到记忆是如何运作的以及它何时会失效。在20世纪30年代，弗雷德里克·巴特利特进行了一项实验，揭示了记忆的一个非常有趣的方面。
The experiment revolved around a story, a Native American legend called the War of the Ghosts. One night, two young men from Egulac went down to the river to hunt seals, and while they were there, it became foggy and calm. Then they heard war cries and they thought, maybe this is a warpalsie, they escaped to the shore and hid behind a log. Now canoes came up and they heard the noise of paddles and saw one canoe coming up to them. They'll find many more canoes. Frederick Bartlett tested the volunteers on what they remembered of the story, sometimes hours later, sometimes days, even months and years later. And what he found was there were these systematic changes to the way these individuals were
该实验围绕着一个故事展开，这是一个名为《幽灵之战》的美洲原住民传说。一天晚上，埃古拉克的两个年轻男子去河边捕海豹，正当他们在那里时，天气变得起雾而且风平浪静。然后他们听到战争的呐喊声，他们想，也许这是一支作战部队，他们逃到岸边，藏在一根圆木后面。这时独木舟划了过来，他们听到桨的声音，看到一只独木舟朝他们划来。他们会发现更多的独木舟。弗雷德里克·巴特利特测试了志愿者对这个故事的记忆，有时是在几小时后，有时是几天，甚至几个月和几年后。他发现，这些个体在
recalling. They forgot details that were foreign to them. So it was a native story about these ghosts warring during dreams. And so many of the subjects just didn't remember some of these elements that were foreign to their cultural understanding. Many of the subjects also made systematic changes where a word like canoe was changed to boat.
回忆时发生了系统性的改变。他们忘记了对他们来说陌生的细节。所以这是一个关于这些幽灵在梦中交战的原住民故事。因此，许多受试者干脆记不住其中一些不符合他们文化理解的元素。许多受试者还作出了系统性的改变，比如将“独木舟”这个词改成了“小船”。
And so what he found was that the subjects when they were retelling the story, they were changing the story so that it aligned with their prior experiences because those prior experiences help us generally to remember information from our autobiography. But what those prior experiences are doing is they are putting those new experiences into a just like story where we have an idea of how things unfold but we don't remember the specific details. In other words, the forgetting wasn't just random. Herman Ebinghaus had suggested that memory was like a sieve. You put stuff in and it falls out gradually over time.
因此他发现，受试者在重述这个故事时，他们改变了故事，使其符合他们先前的经验，因为这些先前的经验通常有助于我们从自传中回忆起信息。但这些先前的经验所做的是，它们将这些新的经验放进了一个类似故事的框架中，在这个框架中我们对事情的发展有了一个概念，但我们并不记得具体的细节。换句话说，遗忘并不仅仅是随机的。赫尔曼·艾宾浩斯曾暗示记忆就像一个筛子。你把东西放进去，它随着时间推移逐渐漏掉。
Frederick Bartlett said, no, there are certain things that get remembered and certain things that get forgotten. What you already know, what you're familiar with, that shapes what you remember, what you can recall, and what gets forgotten. Effectively, what the experiment showed is that when we recalled something, what we remember is only partly about the thing we are remembering. Our memories are also shaped by all the other things we know. Things that are similar to what we already know are more likely to stick. Things that are less similar are likely to drop off or get modified so they fit better with what we already remember. Memory in other words is not a simple process
弗雷德里克·巴特利特说，不，有些事情会被记住，有些事情会被遗忘。你已经知道的、你熟悉的东西，会塑造你所记住的、你所能回忆起的以及被遗忘的东西。实际上，实验表明，当我们回忆某事时，我们所记住的只是部分关于我们正在记忆的事物。我们的记忆同样受到我们所知道的所有其他事物的塑造。与我们已知事物相似的事物更有可能留存下来。不太相似的事物往往会丢失或被修改，以便更好地吻合我们已经记住的内容。换句话说，记忆并不是一个简单的过程：
of opening a mental file drawer and taking things out. It involves a process of reconstruction. And I always think about it like a paleontologist. We're a paleontologist, uncovers a fossil, just as we have uncovered a memory. We remember a piece of an element. And we have a piece of the puzzle that we start putting together with other fossil pieces that have been uncovered. And we reconstruct a, you know, from the paleontologist perspective, maybe a skeleton of a dinosaur.
打开一个心理档案抽屉并把东西拿出来。它涉及一个重建的过程。我总是把它比作古生物学家。就像古生物学家发掘出一块化石一样，我们也发掘出了一段记忆。我们记住了元素的一个片段。我们手里有一块拼图碎片，我们开始把它与已经出土的其他化石碎片拼凑在一起。然后我们重建了一个，你知道的，从古生物学家的角度来看，也许是一具恐龙骨架。
From our perspective, we reconstruct a memory of a past event. But that paleontologist doesn't have all of the pieces. And what that individual has to do is fill in the gaps with best guesses and prior experience. With that person's expertise on what could go there, just as we fill in the gaps of are these memory holes with our best guess of what could go there. I mean, that is both wonderful and terrifying at the same time, Ayanna. Yeah, I think it's really interesting. I think it's really interesting to think about why we do these things, why we
从我们的角度来看，我们重建了对过去事件的记忆。但那位古生物学家并没有所有的碎片。他或她必须做的是用最佳猜测和先验经验来填补空白。凭借那个人对什么可能会在那里的专业知识，就像我们用对什么可能会在那里的最佳猜测来填补记忆空白的缝隙一样。我的意思是，阿亚娜，这既奇妙又可怕。是的，我认为这真的很有趣。我认为思考我们为什么要做这些事情，为什么我们
misrecollect our past, how those kinds of reconstruction errors occur. And I think about it in my own personal life, I share my memories with my partner. And many of us who have partners, we have these sort of collaborative ways in which we recollect. But those collaborations often result in my incorporating information into my memories
会错误回忆我们的过去，这种重建错误是如何发生的，真的非常有趣。我在自己的个人生活中也会这样想，我与伴侣分享我的记忆。我们许多有伴侣的人，都有这种合作回忆的方式。但这些合作往往导致我将信息融入到我的记忆中，
that were suggested by this individual, but I never experienced. And so I might have this vivid recollection of something that only my partner experienced, because we've shared that information so often. And so that's how we can distort memories in the laboratory. We can just get individuals to try and reconstruct events over and over and over again.
而这些信息是由这个人暗示的，但我从未经历过。因此，我可能会对只有我伴侣经历过的事情产生生动的回忆，因为我们太频繁地分享这些信息了。这就是我们如何在实验室中扭曲记忆。我们可以让人不断地、不断地、不断地尝试重建事件。
And with each reconstructive process, they become more and more confident that that event has occurred. So I want to look at this process of mental paleontology a little more carefully. And there will be a number of experiments that have been conducted along these lines, which ask people in some ways to place themselves emotionally in events, and these experiments find that we change what we remember as a result of these interventions. Yes, there have been so many experiments now, I guess, I guess we're talking about 25 years worth of research. Looking at how people come to believe in things that never occurred.
随着每一个重建过程，他们对该事件发生的信心会越来越高。因此，我想更仔细地研究这种心理古生物学的过程。沿着这些思路已经进行了许多实验，它们在某种程度上要求人们在情感上将自己置于事件中，而这些实验发现，由于这些干预措施，我们改变了我们所记忆的内容。是的，现在已经有了那么多的实验，我想，我们谈论的是长达25年的研究。研究人们如何开始相信从未发生过的事情。
And so we see that people can come to believe that they were lost or that they took a hot air balloon ride or spilled punch on the parents of a bride at a wedding when they were young. And generally the way that these studies work is we get some sort of information about kind of events that had happened to them or had not happened to them before the age of, let's say, 10. And then that individual goes through
因此我们看到，人们可能会开始相信他们在年轻时曾迷路过，或者坐过热气球，或者在婚礼上把潘趣酒洒在了新娘父母身上。一般来说，这些研究的运作方式是，我们获得一些关于他们在10岁之前发生过或没有发生过的事情的信息。然后该个人会经历
some sort of suggestion procedure. Researchers wanted to see if they could induce volunteers to develop false memories. In several studies, they described events to volunteers and then told them that they had drawn these accounts from conversations with their parents or siblings. Another study used a more high-tech method. One of my colleagues went as far as distorting pictures using Photoshop and inserting participants into the picture of a hot air balloon. And finding that resulted in, of course, creating this whole false memory
某种暗示程序。研究人员想看看他们是否能诱导志愿者产生虚假记忆。在几项研究中，他们向志愿者描述了事件，然后告诉他们，这些叙述是从与他们父母或兄弟姐妹的对话中提取出来的。另一项研究使用了更高科技的方法。我的一位同事甚至使用Photoshop扭曲图片，将参与者合成到热气球的图片中。结果发现，这当然导致了虚假记忆的产生，
of an event that never took place. And that's quite a distinct event, right? Taking a hot air balloon ride, even you would think you would remember that, and if you didn't remember that, you would think you would probably never have happened. So the fact that this was Kim Wade and colleagues, the fact that she was able to distort individuals with this technique really demonstrates the suggestive nature of pictures. And so personally, you know, I have this experience when I look at old photo albums that my parents have collected, that I go back and I'll look at these old pictures of myself.
一段从未发生过的事件的虚假记忆。这是一件非常独特的事件，对吧？乘坐热气球，你甚至会觉得你会记得这件事，如果你不记得这件事，你可能会觉得它大概永远没有发生过。因此，金·韦德（Kim Wade）及其同事的研究表明，她能够用这种技术扭曲个人，这真正证明了图片的暗示性。因此，就我个人而言，你知道的，当我看着我父母收集的旧相册时，我会有这种经历，我会回去看这些我自己的旧照片。
And, you know, I'm a five graduating from kindergarten and I'll see these pictures and I have no memory of these events but you've had this experience we've all had this experience where you see a picture and you start to think oh yeah kind of remember that it's like you're with your wife and she's suggesting something, pictures are even more distorting from that perspective because we can mentally generate that image and that mental generation is a big cue to us. And in some ways stories function the same way. I remember my parents telling me a story, and I don't have any personal recollection of this, but it tells me a story when I was a very small child. And there was a family gathering at our home, and many people had come over. And as with many Asian households,
你知道的，我五岁幼儿园毕业，我会看到这些照片，我对这些事情没有任何记忆，但你有过这种经历，我们都有过这种经历，当你看到一张照片时，你开始想，哦，是的，我有点记起来了，这就像你和你的妻子在一起，她在暗示什么一样，从这个角度来看，图片甚至更具扭曲性，因为我们可以在脑海中生成那个图像，而这种心理生成对我们来说是一个巨大的线索。在某种程度上，故事也是这样运作的。我记得我父母给我讲过一个故事，我对这件事没有任何个人记忆，但当我还是个小孩子时，他们给我讲过这个故事。当时家里有一个家庭聚会，许多人都来了。就像许多亚裔家庭一样，
people left their footwear at the door or at the entrance to the house before coming in. And apparently, I sort of wandered off from this gathering, and I essentially stole everyone's left shoe or left slipper. And basically took all the left shoes and left slippers that basically moved them to a new location. And I have obviously no recollection whatsoever of doing this, but I've heard the story so many times that to me I can actually sort of vaguely see myself doing this. And I feel also vaguely proud that even at the age of two I could pick out just the left slippers from the right ones. I think they're making that up. I don't see how a two-year-old could have really done that. I think that you might have stolen a few shoes and this story has changed so much over the
人们在进门前会把鞋子留在门口或房子的入口处。显然，我不知怎么从这个聚会中溜走了，基本上偷走了每个人的左鞋或左拖鞋。基本上拿走了所有的左鞋和左拖鞋，把它们搬到了一个新的地方。我显然完全不记得自己做过这件事，但我听这个故事听了太多次，以至于我实际上可以隐约看到自己当时在做这件事。我甚至隐约感到骄傲，因为我两岁时就能从右拖鞋中挑出左拖鞋。我觉得他们在瞎编。我不认为一个两岁的小孩真的能做到这一点。我觉得你可能偷了几只鞋，这个故事在过去
years. Can you imagine? So that's very sad, Ayanna, you know, ruining one of my precious childhood memories. Well, if it really did happen, that's very sad, Ayanna, you know, the ruining one of my precious childhood memories. Well, if it really did happen, that's pretty amazing. I'm gonna go with that version. I'm gonna go with that version. What Ayanna and other researchers have found over and over again is that our memories are fallible. And the implications of this extend far beyond how we think about our own childhoods.
几年里被改得面目全非。你能想象吗？所以这太令人伤心了，阿亚娜，你知道的，毁了我珍贵的童年记忆之一。好吧，如果它真的发生了，那真的很惊人。我选择相信那个版本。我选择相信那个版本。阿亚娜和其他研究人员一次又一次发现的是，我们的记忆是不可靠的。这带来的影响远远超出了我们对自身童年的看法。
They extended to serious settings like the criminal justice system where we constantly ask people to make recollections or remember things under oath. Do people remember things accurately? In the early 1970s Elizabeth Laftus and John Palmer ran an experiment to find out. What they were really interested in was how people recollect a witnessed event, and how the way in which questions are phrased influence our recollection. The researchers showed their volunteers short films of car accidents. Then they asked the volunteers some questions about what they had just seen.
它们延伸到了严肃的领域，比如刑事司法系统，我们在那里不断要求人们在宣誓下进行回忆或记忆事情。人们能准确地记住事情吗？在20世纪70年代初，伊丽莎白·洛夫图斯（Elizabeth Loftus）和约翰·帕尔默（John Palmer）进行了一项实验来找出答案。他们真正感兴趣的是人们如何回忆目击事件，以及问题的提问方式如何影响我们的回忆。研究人员向他们的志愿者展示了车祸的短片。然后他们问了志愿者一些关于他们刚刚看到的情况的问题。
And there was a critical manipulation in the first experiment. What they did between groups of participants was they changed one word in the question. Some people were asked how fast were the cars going when they contacted each other? Others were asked the question with a more vivid verb, like how fast were the cars going when they bumped into each other, smashed into each other, or hit each other? The people who heard the word smashed or collided recall that the cars were going faster than the people who heard the word bumped. So changing just one word in the question changed people's memory of the speed of the cars. Then there was something else. The volunteers were asked whether there was broken glass at the scene of the accident. The researchers found that volunteers were much more likely to remember seeing broken glass
在第一个实验中有一个关键的操作。他们在不同组的参与者之间所做的是，他们改变了问题中的一个字。一些人被问到：当两车相互接触时，车速有多快？另一些人则被问到一个更生动的动词，比如：当两车碰撞、猛烈撞击或撞上彼及时，车速有多快？听到“猛烈撞击”或“相撞”这个词的人回忆说，汽车的速度比听到“碰撞”这个词的人要快。因此，仅仅改变问题中的一个词就改变了人们对汽车速度的记忆。还有另一件事。志愿者被问及事故现场是否有碎玻璃。研究人员发现，如果使用了“猛烈撞击”或“撞上”等词，志愿者
if the words smashed or hit had been used. And I think it's really important to note that there was no broken glass in any of the images that participants were shown in the study. So not only did it change their estimates of speed, which is subjective in and of itself, but participants distorted their recollection in the active recalling because of the word that was used. And so with no broken glass being present, participants remembered broken glass because
就更有可能记得看到过碎玻璃。我认为非常重要的一点是，在研究中向参与者展示的任何图像中都没有碎玻璃。因此，这不仅改变了他们对速度的估计（速度本身是主观的），而且参与者由于使用的词语而在回忆的积极过程中扭曲了他们的回忆。因此，在没有碎玻璃的情况下，参与者却记起了碎玻璃，因为
that question was posed in a particularly suggestive way. So this has really important implications for criminal justice and how we question witnesses, how we get information about investigations from witnesses, the way in which officers at the scene of the crime, investigators during the context of interviews, the ways in which they question witnesses, whether witnesses are questioned together, whether witnesses talk to one another after the fact, and now in the age of social media, now witnesses being able to do their own online investigations. All of these elements are serving to introduce factors that can distort the recollection of witnesses. What is especially dangerous about this is that when people think back, they
这个问题是以一种特别具有暗示性的方式提出的。因此，这对刑事司法以及我们如何讯问证人、我们如何从证人那里获取调查信息、犯罪现场的警官、采访过程中的调查人员他们讯问证人的方式、证人是否被共同讯问、证人事后是否互相交谈，以及现在在社交媒体时代，证人能够自己进行在线调查——所有这些因素都在引入可能扭曲证人回忆的因素。这特别危险的地方在于，当人们回想时，他们
can actually tell which of those memories is real and which was made up. After some time, I can't distinguish between the things I actually remember and the things that I've reconstructed, they both feel exactly the same. And I think you're hitting on one of the issues, right? You think that some memories that you have are, as you say, actually remembered, but they're all reconstructed. The question is, which reconstructed memories are more accurate? And can you learn to monitor that process?
实际上无法分辨哪些记忆是真实的，哪些是虚构的。一段时间后，我无法区分我实际记得的事情和我重建的事情，它们的真实感完全一样。我想你切中了问题的一个核心，对吧？你认为你拥有的一些记忆，正如你所说，是真实记忆，但它们其实全都是重建的。问题是，哪些重建的记忆更准确？你能学会监控这个过程吗？
And I think people can. Coming up, we delve more deeply into Ayana's research to understand the many ways our memories can fail us. The stories we tell ourselves about past events can also change the way we remember the past. Ayanna once brought volunteers into the lab and asked them to imagine doing both ordinary things like bouncing a ball and bizarre things like kissing a magnifying glass. I asked her why she did this and what she found. We were really interested in whether people could accurately distinguish between what they imagined
我认为人们可以。接下来，我们将深入探讨阿亚娜的研究，以了解我们的记忆可能失灵的多种方式。我们对自己讲述的关于过去事件的故事，也会改变我们回忆过去的方式。阿亚娜曾经把志愿者带进实验室，让他们想象做一些普通的事情，比如拍球，以及做一些离奇的事情，比如亲吻放大镜。我问她为什么要这么做以及她发现了什么。我们非常感兴趣的是，人们是否能够准确地分辨出他们想象的事情
versus what they actually did. And we compared performance on very simple, common kinds of activities that people would do in their daily lives, that they could easily think, of course I did that, as compared to things that they would never do, like we had kissing magnifying glasses and rubbing lotion on the chair, very strange things that people generally would not do in their daily lives. And so they did some of these things and they imagined some of these things, but critically what we did was we brought them back in on a second session and we just had them imagine
与他们实际做的事情。我们将人们日常生活中会做的非常简单、常见活动的表现进行对比，这些活动他们可以很容易地认为“我当然做过”，而那些他们永远不会做的事情则作为对比，比如我们让受试者亲吻放大镜、在椅子上涂抹乳液，这些都是人们在日常生活中通常不会做的非常奇怪的事情。因此，他们做了一些事情，也想象了一些事情，但关键是我们在第二阶段把他们请了回来，我们只是让他们想象
a bunch of some of these activities over and over and over and over again. And what we found when we tested them two weeks later was that when people imagined these actions, whether they were sort of usual common kinds of actions, like bouncing the ball, or unusual actions, like kissing the magnifying glass. It regardless of the bizarnas of the act, the more times people imagined it, the more likely they were to say that actually they performed it on that first day. So we were able to get people to believe that they did these strange things when they only imagined them repeatedly. And so you can extrapolate and say, well, can you get people to
其中的一系列活动，一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地想象。当我们两周后对他们进行测试时，我们发现，当人们想象这些行动时，无论是通常的常见行动，比如拍球，还是不同寻常的行动，比如亲吻放大镜。无论行为有多离奇，人们想象它的次数越多，他们就越倾向于说他们在第一天确实执行了该行动。因此，我们能够让人相信他们做了这些奇怪的事情，而他们实际上只是反复地想象了这些事情。所以你可以推断并说，好吧，你能让人
believe they've done very strange things in their lives that they would never have done? And I think the answer is yes, you can. Now you did find that people were less likely to remember doing the bizarre things than the ordinary things. So it was easier to say, I remember bouncing the ball the first time I came in, rather than I kissed the magnifying glass the first time I came in, but there were errors on both counts. Indeed. last the first time I came in, but there were errors on both counts.
相信他们在生活中做过一些他们永远不会做的非常奇怪的事情吗？我认为答案是肯定的，你可以。不过，你确实发现人们不太记得自己做过离奇的事情，而不是普通的事情。因此，说“我记得我第一次进来时拍了球”，要比说“我第一次进来时亲吻了放大镜”更容易，但在两方面都存在错误。确实如此。第一次进来时亲吻了放大镜，但在两方面都存在错误。
Indeed. So it's easier to distort people's memories if the information is plausible. The more common, the more usual, the more easy it is for people to imagine themselves in this activity and maybe pull from their prior experience to distort their memory. And so the more unusual, the less plausible something is, the less likely it is for people to come to believe that these events took place or that they engaged in some particular activity. So it's interesting when I think back to that childhood memory of my taking everyone's left slippers, one of the things that I realized my brain is doing is that in my mental image of that scene, I'm painting a picture of myself
确实如此。因此，如果信息是合理的话，更容易扭曲人们的记忆。越常见、越习惯、越容易让人想象自己参与这项活动，并可能从他们先前的经验中汲取营养来扭曲他们的记忆。因此，越是不寻常、越是不可信的事情，人们就越不可能相信这些事件发生过或他们参与了某项特定的活动。所以，当我回想起我拿走所有人左拖鞋的那段童年记忆时，有趣的是，我意识到我的大脑正在做的是，在我对那个场景的心理图像中，我把自己画成
dressed in the clothes that I've seen myself wear in a childhood photograph. And of course, I have no idea whether I was wearing those clothes on the day that this particular event happened. And as you say, it might never have happened. But it's interesting that I'm fleshing out things that actually I have no idea about using different elements of what I know about the past in a way to create essentially this picture that makes sense of a past event that I don't actually
穿着我在童年照片中看到自己穿过的衣服。当然，我完全不知道在这个特定事件发生的当天我是否穿着那些衣服。正如你所说，它可能根本就没有发生过。但有趣的是，我正在利用我对过去的了解的不同元素，来充实那些我实际上毫无所知的事情，以创造出基本上能够合理解释一个我其实并不
remember. And those pictures of our when we were children are highly suggestive of the way that we construct our childhood memories. I've seen myself in, I think, one or two outfits in pictures. And those are, that's pretty much how I imagine prior events. I must have been wearing the stress. Obviously, I had more than two dresses, or maybe I didn't. But I don't know. In fact, I remember very little from those early days. So yeah, we use our pictures, we use those stories.
记得的过去事件的画面。当我们还是孩子时的那些照片，对我们构建童年记忆的方式具有极大的暗示性。我看到过自己在照片中穿的一两套衣服。这些基本上就是我如何想象先前事件的方式。我当时一定穿着这件衣服。显然，我穿的不止两条裙子，或者也许我没有。但我不知道。事实上，我对那些早期的日子记得很少。所以，是的，我们使用我们的照片，我们使用那些故事。
Your family has embellished and you stole all the left shoes. And those all served to create a really fun story to tell, but maybe not an accurate depiction of what actually took place. The fact that memory often is not an accurate depiction of what took place can help us understand how two people can have very different recollections of the same event. You affirm that the testimony you're about to give before the committee will be the truth, the whole truth and nothing but the truth, so I hope you guys. I do.
你的家族进行了美化，而你偷走了所有的左鞋。这些都有助于创造一个讲述起来非常有趣的故事，但可能并不是对实际发生事情的准确描绘。记忆往往不是对实际发生事情的准确描绘这一事实，可以帮助我们理解为什么两个人对同一事件会有截然不同的回忆。你确认你即将向委员会做出的证词将是真相、全部真相，而且只有真相，所以我希望你们。我确认。
Yeah. And one of the things I wanted to ask you is when you see stories breaking in the news that revolve around people's recollections of events, I'm wondering how you as a memory researcher process these stories. And the story that springs to mind is the one that occurred some time ago, where Christine Blasie Ford accused now Supreme Court Justice Brett Kavanaugh of sexually assaulting her when they were both teenagers. I don't have all the answers, and I don't remember as much as I would like to, but the details
是的。我想问你的一件事是，当你看到新闻中爆发围绕人们对事件回忆的故事时，作为一名记忆研究人员，我很好奇你是如何看待这些故事的。浮现在我脑海中的故事是前不久发生的那件事，当时克里斯蒂娜·布拉西·福特（Christine Blasey Ford）指控现任最高法院大法官布雷特·卡瓦诺（Brett Kavanaugh）在两人都是青少年时对她实施了性侵犯。我没有所有的答案，我也不记得我想记得的那么多，但是关于那个夜晚的细节，
that about that night that bring me here today are the ones I will never forget. They have been... She said she had a very vivid memory of this happening. Brett and Mark came into the bedroom and locked the door behind them. There was music playing in the bedroom. He said that it did not happen. I categorically and unequivocally deny the allegation
那些把我带到这里来的细节，是我永远不会忘记的。它们已经被……她说她对这件事有非常生动的记忆。布雷特和马克走进卧室，把身后的门锁上了。卧室里放着音乐。他说这并没有发生。我明确且毫不含糊地否认福特博士
against me by Dr. Ford. I never had any sexual or physical encounter of any kind with Dr. Ford. I never attended a gathering. And in some ways, the country was divided over these dueling memories. What would you have said if you were on the expert witness stand about how to understand these two very different recollections about an event. Well, I think that it's important to note that both individuals could be recalling that night as accurately as they could. But the
对我的指控。我从未与福特博士有过任何形式的性接触或身体接触。我从未参加过那种聚会。在某种程度上，整个国家因这两种针锋相对的记忆而分裂。如果你坐在专家证人席上，你会对如何理解关于某一事件的这两种截然不同的回忆说些什么呢？嗯，我认为重要的是要注意，这两个人可能都在尽可能准确地回忆那个夜晚。但是，
interpretation of saying that this couldn't have happened because I would have remembered it is an inappropriate interpretation of how memory works. Of course it could have happened and you have forgotten it. Because often we will remember things that are particularly salient to us. And so sometimes we forget things that maybe are really important to other people because they weren't that big of a deal to us. And so I use the analogy of my brother and I. My brother and I have lots of shared childhood memories. He's three years younger than me. And he will tell me stories that he remembers very well and I have no recollection.
认为“这不可能发生，因为我会记得”是对记忆运作方式的不恰当解释。它当然可能发生过，而你已经忘记了。因为通常我们会记住那些对我们特别突出的事情。所以有时我们会忘记那些对其他人来说可能非常重要的事情，因为它们对我们来说并不是什么大不了的事。因此，我用了我和我兄弟的类比。我和我兄弟有很多共同的童年记忆。他比我小三岁。他会给我讲他记得很清楚的故事，而我一点印象也没有。
And it's because it wasn't that big of a deal to me, but it was a big deal to him. And so, I think the important thing in the Blasey Ford and Kavanaugh cases, they both, neither necessarily, were lying about the, that past. It's just that memories are going to differentially degrade and differentially be distorted for different individuals. Do I know who was accurate in that retelling?
那是因为这对我说不是什么大不了的事，但对他是件大事。因此，我认为在布拉西·福特和卡瓦诺的案件中，他们俩都不一定是在对那个过去说谎。只是记忆会因不同的人而产生差异化的退化和差异化的扭曲。我知道谁在那次重述中是准确的吗？
I don't. Could both have been distorted? Most definitely. What was interesting to me based on what you've told me for the last several minutes is that I think many of us believe that the more vividly we recall something the more it must have happened. And I think when a lot of people watched the disagreement unfold on national television, we said, well, she clearly believes it did happen. And he clearly believes it didn't happen. And only one of them therefore must be true and the other one must be lying. Because if they both vividly recalled this, clearly they both would have remembered something
我不知道。两人的记忆都可能被扭曲了吗？绝对有可能。根据你过去几分钟所告诉我的，对我来说有趣的是，我认为我们中的许多人相信，我们对某事的记忆越生动，它就越一定是真的。我想当很多人在全国电视上观看这场分歧展开时，我们会说，好吧，她显然相信它发生了。而他显然相信它没有发生。因此，其中只有一个人必须是真的，另一个人一定在撒谎。因为如果他们都生动地回忆起这一点，显然他们俩都会记住如此惊人的事情
as astonishing as this happening or something as out of the ordinary as this happening. And in some ways what you're suggesting is actually more difficult to stop up, which is that they both could have been telling the truth, or they both couldn't, in some ways, have been making up something without actually realizing it. Exactly. You know, you hear these people say, oh, I believe this individual or
或如此不同寻常的事情发生。在某种程度上，你所暗示的其实更难厘清，那就是他们俩可能都在说实话，或者他们在某种程度上，可能在不知不觉中捏造了某些东西。完全正确。你知道，你会听到人们说，哦，我信任这个人，或者
I believe this other individual and the question's not about belief. Both have their own versions of the truth and that what people have to私を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を手を I do not know. I always think back to, have you ever seen that movie, Rashomon? Yeah. I'm sorry for that. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Rashomon's a great movie to think about from this context, because you have a retelling of an eyewitnessed event.
我信任另一个人，而问题不在于信任。双方都有他们各自版本的真相，而人们必须……我总是回想起，你看过那部电影《罗生门》吗？看过。我很抱歉。我很抱歉。我很抱歉。从这个背景来思考，《罗生门》是一部极好的电影，因为你看到了对目击事件的重述。
And some of the witnesses to this crime have motivation to lie. But some don't. And they just tell a different version from their own perspective. And this is really what's going on generally when we are telling about a past event, even if it's traumatic, we're telling it from our perspective. And that perspective alters our recollection. Just as we are sometimes too confident about our memories, Ayanna says there are other times
该犯罪的一些目击者有撒谎的动机。但有些人没有。他们只是从自己的角度讲述了不同的版本。这确实是我们讲述过去事件时普遍发生的情况，即使它是创伤性的，我们也是从我们的角度来讲述的。而这种角度改变了我们的回忆。正如我们有时对自己的记忆过于自信一样，阿亚娜说还有其他时候
when we're too insecure. When we jump to the conclusion our memories are failing us. Take for example the experience that many older people report in forgetting where they left their keys or where they parked their car. And I used to think that older adults actually are demonstrating more of these memory failures than their younger counterparts. And to some extent that's true, there is age-related decline in attention processes and memory encoding processes that likely result in these kinds of errors
我们过于不自信。当我们轻率地得出结论，认为我们的记忆正在衰退时。以许多老年人报告的忘记把钥匙放在哪里或把车停在哪里为例。我过去常常认为，与年轻人相比，老年人确实表现出更多的这种记忆失灵。在某种程度上这是真的，注意力过程和记忆编码过程确实存在与年龄相关的衰退，这很可能会导致这类错误，
and will increase the frequency of these errors. But I also think that older adults are just more sensitive to these kinds of errors and are more likely to remember the error than their younger counterparts. Because many individuals, as they get older, become more sensitive to potential problems with their cognition and their aging. Whenever they have these kinds of failures, those failures are more salient until they remember them more.
并会增加这些错误的频率。但我也认为，老年人对这类错误更加敏感，与年轻人相比，他们更有可能记住这个错误。因为许多人在变老时，对认知和衰老方面的潜在问题变得更加敏感。每当他们有这种失灵时，这些失灵就更加突出，直到他们记住它们更多。
So I think there's also a bias in reporting where there's under reporting for younger people and over reporting for older people. And you and others have also found that if you, in some ways, frame challenges as being about declining memory, you're more likely to see errors among older people in a phenomenon that sometimes call stereotype threat. Right. And so, and I do this work in collaboration with my colleague, Marie Mezzroil, and we've really interested in how when you either activate or alleviate threat
因此我认为，在报告中也存在一种偏差，即年轻人的报告不足，而老年人的报告过多。你和其他人还发现，如果在某种程度上将挑战框定为记忆衰退，你更有可能在老年人中看到错误，这种现象有时被称为刻板印象威胁。没错。而且，我和我的同事玛丽·梅兹罗伊（Marie Mazzuchelli）合作开展这项研究，我们真正感兴趣的是，当你激活或减轻老年人的威胁时，
in older adults, how that influences memory and other cognitive processes. And so what I mean by that is there is a negative stereotype associated with getting older and implicit in that negative stereotype is that you're going to demonstrate these cognitive deficits. And in fact, the majority of time I bring people into the lab that are, let's say, over the age of 65, they're coming into the cognitive aging and memory lab. And the first thing they say to me
这会如何影响记忆和其他认知过程。我的意思是，存在一种与变老相关的负面刻板印象，而该负面刻板印象中隐含的意思是，你将表现出这些认知缺陷。事实上，我把年龄在65岁以上的人带进实验室的大多数时候，他们都是来到认知衰老和记忆实验室。他们对我说第一句话是
or the researchers who are testing them as well, you know, I have a terrible memory or I'm really worried about my memory. They're already feeling threatened about their memory. And that psychological experience of just worrying about one's memory tends to negatively impact performance on memory tests. And so when you reduce that anxiety and you alleviate that threat, older individuals do better.
或者那些正在测试他们的研究人员，你知道，我记忆力很差，或者我很担心我的记忆力。他们已经对自己的记忆力感到威胁。仅仅为自己的记忆力担心的心理体验往往会对记忆测试的表现产生负面影响。因此，当你减少这种焦虑并消除这种威胁时，老年人的表现就会更好。
When we come back, how all of us can improve our ability to remember things. Because memory works in predictable ways, it turns out there are specific things you can do to make your own memory better. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. What you're hearing is the voice of a man named Nelson Delis. He's what's known as a memory athlete. Five of the states, eight of the states, seven of the clubs. Memory athletes memorize huge quantities of information, like strings of numbers, lists of words, and decks of cards. This is Nelson at a memory championship in 2014.
当我们回来时，探讨我们所有人如何提高记忆事物的能力。因为记忆以可预测的方式运作，事实证明，你可以做一些具体的事情来让你的记忆力更好。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹坦。你听到的是一个名叫纳尔逊·德利斯的人的声音。他被称为记忆运动员。五个州，八个州，七张梅花。记忆运动员可以记住大量的信息，比如一串数字、单词列表和一副扑克牌。这是纳尔逊在2014年记忆锦标赛上的表现。
Jack of Hearts, ten of hearts. This is Nelson at a memory championship in 2014. Jack of Hearts, 10 of Hearts. I really love watching memory competitions and watching these memory athletes be able to rehearse back long strings of numbers and recite back long passages from books. Seven of us. and recite back long passages from books. They are just like us.
红桃J，红桃10。这是纳尔逊在2014年记忆锦标赛上的表现。红桃J，红桃10。我真的很喜欢看记忆比赛，看着这些记忆运动员能够复述一长串数字，并背诵书中的长篇大论。我们中的七个人。并背诵书中的长篇大论。他们就像我们一样。
And we could do what they do. And what they're doing is they're using memory like a skill that can be honed and perfected. the homes and perfected. So how do memory athletes imprint all this information in their minds? One of the most popular techniques is called a memory palace. You create a mental image of a familiar location like your house or the street where you grew up. Then you plan out a path through that space,
我们也可以做他们正在做的事情。他们正在做的是把记忆当作一种可以磨练和完善的技能。磨练和完善。那么，记忆运动员是如何将所有这些信息印在他们的脑海中的呢？最流行的技术之一被称为记忆宫殿。你在脑海中创造一个熟悉地方的心理图像，比如你的房子或你长大的街道。然后你规划出一条穿过那个空间的路径，
creating conspicuous stops along the way. Once you've done that, place all the items you want to remember at each of those stops. This mental image, the location, the path, the stops with the items on it, this becomes your memory palace. Here's an example. Let's say you want to remember four things on a list. For a speaker location, like your house, now make a path with four stops along the way. You might start at the front door,
沿途设置显眼的停靠点。一旦你这样做了，把你想要记住的所有物品放在这些停靠点的每一个上面。这个心理图像，地点，路径，带有物品的停靠点，这就成了你的记忆宫殿。这里有一个例子。假设你想记住列表上的四件事。对于一个具体的地点，比如你的房子，现在沿着这条路制造四个停靠点。你可以从前门开始，
then stop at your coat closet, followed by the kitchen, then the bedroom. Now go back and mentally place the four things you want to remember at each of those locations. Once you've done this, remembering your list gets easier. Just walk through your house in your mind and look at the four things along the path. The memory palace is based on the idea that to remember things that are unfamiliar, you want to hook them onto things that are familiar.
然后在你的衣柜停下，接着是厨房，然后是卧室。现在回去，在每一个地点精神上放置你想要记住的四件事。一旦你完成了这一步，记住你的列表就变得更容易了。只需在脑海中穿过你的房子，看着沿途的四件事。记忆宫殿的基础是这样一个理念：为了记住不熟悉的事情，你想把它们挂在你熟悉的事情上。
It's an ancient technique going back to Greek and Roman orators who often had to learn long speeches by heart. What individuals would be doing when they were giving speeches is they would associate elements of the speech to different individuals seated in the room. If people were sitting in the same place in specific rooms, they would be able to associate, let's say the first sign of the speech with a person sitting in the first row on the right
这是一项古老的技术，可以追溯到希腊和罗马的演说家，他们经常必须用心背诵长篇演讲。个人在发表演讲时所做的事情，是将演讲的元素与坐在房间里的不同个人联系起来。如果人们坐在特定房间的同一个地方，他们就能够把，比方说演讲的第一个标志与坐在右侧第一排的人联系起来
and so on and so forth. And so all these speakers would have to do is look across the room to be able to remember the different elements of the speech. What's so fascinating about what you're saying Ayanna in some ways is that the very same processes that in some ways can contaminate memory, which is our past experiences, the things that we know well, can contaminate the things that we learn, the things that happen to us because memory is reconstructed. You can actually use this now to actually improve your memory. You can actually use it to remember things that
以此类推。因此，所有这些演讲者所要做的就是看一眼房间，就能记住演讲的不同要素。艾安娜，你所说的话在某些方面如此迷人，那就是在某些方面可以污染记忆的完全相同的过程，也就是我们的过去经验，我们非常了解的事情，会污染我们学习的东西，发生在我们身上的事情，因为记忆是重建的。你实际上现在可以用它来真正改善你的记忆。你实际上可以用它来记住那些
happen by associating them with other things in your past that you're familiar with. Yes, so we talked about how prior experience can distort memory, but prior experience can also scaffold memory and we can use it to learn new information. I'm wondering if I can give you a list of five things to try and remember and have you essentially put them on a familiar path and have you do this sort of live so we can see how this works. Would you be game to do that? We can try. I will maybe fail miserably. Well, we remember the stereotype threat research though. You shouldn't tell yourself that you want to fail miserably. Well, we remember the stereotype threat research though. You shouldn't, you shouldn't tell yourself
通过将它们与你熟悉的过去的其它事情联系起来而发生的事情。是的，所以我们讨论了先前的经验如何扭曲记忆，但先前的经验也可以为记忆搭建支架，我们可以用它来学习新的信息。我想知道我是否可以给你列出五件要尝试记住的事情，并让你基本上把它们放在一条熟悉的路径上，并让你现场做这件事，这样我们就可以看到这是如何运作的。你愿意这样做吗？我们可以试试。我可能会惨败。嗯，不过我们记得刻板印象威胁的研究。你不应该告诉自己你想惨败。嗯，不过我们记得刻板印象威胁的研究。你不应该，你不应该告诉自己
that you're going to fail miserably. Yes. All right, so the five items I want you to try and remember are milk, eggs, olive oil, garlic, and pink cake frosting. So can you build a memory palace or one of these walks where you're familiar with, where you place these five items that I can tell you them, I can tell each of them to you as you go along the path, so that you will remember them
你要惨败。好的，所以我想让你尝试记住的五样东西是牛奶、鸡蛋、橄榄油、大蒜和粉红色的蛋糕糖霜。那么你能建造一个记忆宫殿或这些你熟悉的步行路线之一吗？你把这五样东西放在那里，我可以告诉你，我可以在你沿路走的时候把每一件都告诉你，这样你会记住它们
in the future. Again, milk, eggs, olive oil, garlic, and pink cake frosting. Okay, I will try. Do you want to try and tell us what you are doing in your head so that we can follow along with you, whatever the path is that you're setting up? Well, for me, actually, I'm thinking about what I would cook with these elements. So I'm making all of these elements interact, and you threw a little curveball in there
在未来。再次强调，牛奶、鸡蛋、橄榄油、大蒜和粉红色蛋糕糖霜。好的，我会试试。你想尝试告诉我们你在脑海中在做什么，以便我们可以跟着你的路径走，无论你正在设置什么路径吗？好吧，对，实际上，我在想我会用这些元素做什么菜。所以我让所有这些元素互动，你在里面扔了一个小曲线球
with garlic, but fortunately garlic is a distinctive element in that list. Because I can make a cake with most of what you've What you already talked about so that helps because now the four elements that were potentially unassociated Are now associated into one unit. So I've made something distinctive a pink frosted garlic cake So terrible frosted garlic cake. So that's terrible. That's not terrible. But what's so interesting here in some ways is
带着大蒜，但幸运的是大蒜是那个列表中的一个独特元素。因为我可以用你讨论过的大多数东西做一个蛋糕，所以这很有帮助，因为现在四个原本可能没有关联的元素现在被联系成了一个单元。所以我做了一个独特的东西，一个粉红色的糖霜大蒜蛋糕。所以这是一个可怕的糖霜大蒜蛋糕。这太糟糕了。这并不可怕。但这里非常有趣的是
you're employing imagination to boost memory. And we talked earlier about how imagination can undermine memory. Isn't it fascinating that it can play these dual roles? Yeah, our imaginations are highly effective in allowing us to remember these disparate pieces of information. And so it is associations that allow us to remember information. And when we are able to make associations, and when we're able to rely on interactive, unusual imagery,
你正在运用想象力来增强记忆力。我们前面讨论了想象力如何会削弱记忆力。它能扮演这双重角色，难道不迷人吗？是的，我们的想象力在让我们记住这些不同的信息片段方面非常有效。因此，正是联系让我们能够记住信息。当我们能够建立联系，当我们能够依赖互动的、不同寻常的意象时，
we're able to remember unrelated lists of items. So the analogy that's bringing to my mind is that to think of memories, individual memories are like islands. We consolidate those memories, but also potentially contaminate them by essentially building bridges to those islands from other islands that we are more familiar with.
我们能够记住不相关的物品列表。因此，浮现在我脑海中的类比是，把记忆想象成独立的岛屿。我们巩固这些记忆，但也可能通过从我们更熟悉的其它岛屿到这些岛屿建立桥梁来污染它们。
Some people talk about this as the difference between learning somebody's name as Baker, and that someone's profession is Baker. If you ask that person to remember, do you remember the person's name, or do you remember the person's profession, it's usually easier to remember the person's profession two weeks later than to remember that somebody
有些人将此称为学习某人的名字叫贝克，而那个人的职业是贝克之间的区别。如果你让那个人记住，你还记得那个人的名字吗，或者你还记得那个人的职业吗，两周后记住那个人的职业通常比记住某人更容易
had a name, Baker. Talk about this idea that in some ways, the context that matters enormously in terms of what it is that we're remembering and something's just come with more context than others. I really like the analogy of thinking about memory as islands. We think about it as memories as nodes, right? So you have a particular concept like Baker. And when I say Baker, a number of related concepts that are connected to those nodes
有个名字叫贝克。谈谈这个想法，在某些方面，情境在很大程度上决定了我们正在记住的内容，有些事情就是比其它事情带有更多的情境。我真的很喜欢把记忆想象成岛屿的类比。我们将其视为作为节点的记忆，对吧？所以你有一个特定的概念，比如贝克。当我说贝克时，许多相关的概念都连接到这些节点
are connected to those islands, those associated bridges that you're talking about are activated. So you think about bread and you think about maybe the time of day that you might go to the bakery. And you think about your time in France, which I just got back from. So now I'm thinking about France. And you think about all of these contextual elements that allow you to strengthen that memory representation. But those notes and those associations can also lead to error.
与那些岛屿相连，你正在谈论的那些相关的桥梁被激活了。所以你想到了面包，你想到了你可能会去面包店的一天中的时间。你想到了你在法国的时光，我刚刚从那里回来。所以我现在在想法国。你想到了所有这些能够让你加强该记忆表征的情境要素。但这些节点和那些联系也可能导致错误。
IANA is also studied ways in which students can get better at retaining information. One of the most effective methods, taking practice tests. Closing your books and forcing yourself to recall information turns out to be a powerful way to remember things you've learned. Another insight, space out learning and avoid trying to cram everything the last night before an exam. Also try to get some sleep. Memory consolidation occurs during sleep and you have to have specific high-quality sleep in order to consolidate these kinds of memories. It's interesting I just read a recent
艾安娜还研究了学生如何更好地保留信息的方法。最有效的方法之一，参加模拟考试。合上书本并强迫自己回忆信息，证明是记住你学过东西的有力方式。另一个见解，间隔学习，避免在考试前的最后一晚试图死记硬背所有东西。还要试着睡个觉。记忆巩固发生在睡眠期间，你必须有特定高质量的睡眠才能巩固这些记忆。有趣的是，我刚刚读了一篇最近的
article about sleep and consolidation and how during the context of sleep cycles we actually select particularly salient memories and that gets preferential consolidation treatment while we're sleeping. In some ways there is an analogy here with physical activity as well, right? Physical, your trainers will tell you, yes, try and come in more than once a week, but they will also tell you if you try and do four hours of physical activity on one day rather than half an hour every day, you're not giving your body time to rest and actually build up strength and stamina and everything else.
关于睡眠和巩固的文章，以及在睡眠周期的背景下，我们实际上如何选择特别突出的记忆，并在我们睡觉时获得优先的巩固处理。在某些方面，这里与体育活动也有类比，对吧？体能，你的教练会告诉你，是的，试着一周来一次以上，但他们也会告诉你，如果你试着在一天内做四个小时的体育活动，而不是每天半小时，你并没有给你的身体时间休息并真正建立力量、耐力和其它一切。
Actually the rest is actually part of what makes the physical activity pay off. Right. So it seems that our body requires a balance in order to engage in the variety of interconnected processes that are going to result in physical change. And a memory and memory formation is a physical change in the brain. And memory retrieval is the act of reconstructing some of those changes and bringing them back together
实际上，休息实际上是使体育活动得到回报的一部分。对。因此，我们的身体似乎需要平衡，以便参与各种相互关联的过程，这些过程将导致身体变化。记忆和记忆形成是大脑中的物理变化。而记忆检索则是重建其中一些变化并将它们重新组合在一起的行为
to make a conscious experience of a recalled event. All right, so I am going to try and see if you remember that list of things that I gave you maybe about 15 or 20 minutes ago. And let's see if you can use your recipe technique, Iana, to remember the five items on that grocery list. Yeah, I'll tell you, I actually thought you were going to ask me this pretty soon. And so I mentally retrieved it right about the time we were talking. And I was like, do I have it?
来对回忆的事件产生有意识的体验。好的，所以我要试着看看你是否还记得我大约15或20分钟前给你的那份东西清单。让我们看看你是否能用你的食谱技术，艾安娜，来记住杂货清单上的五样东西。是的，我告诉你，我其实以为你很快就会问我这个。所以大约在我们交谈的时候，我在脑海中检索了它。我当时想，我有吗？
I think I do. So, is milk eggs, olive oil, garlic, and pink cake frosting. That's spectacular. And I'm sure in years to come, we will both remember the time that you made some delicious garlic cake for us both. I'm very happy with myself. Iana Thomas is a psychologist who studies memory. Why are recollections do not always reflect reality, how memories degrade, and what we can do to retain things better.
我想我有。所以，是牛奶、鸡蛋、橄榄油、大蒜和粉红色蛋糕糖霜。太棒了。我相信在未来的几年里，我们俩都会记住你为我们俩做了一些美味的大蒜蛋糕的那一次。我对自我非常满意。艾安娜·托马斯是一位研究记忆的心理学家。为什么回忆并不总是反映现实，记忆是如何退化的，以及我们可以做些什么来更好地保留事物。
Iana thanks for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you. It was a pleasure. This episode was produced by Laura Quarelle and Parth Shah and edited by Tara Boyle and Raina Cohen. Our team includes Thomas Liu and Jenny Schmidt. Special thanks to Jonathan Burley and Jonas Harnell for their voice acting. Our unsung hero is Yop Mara, a theoretical neuropsychologist at the University of Amsterdam.
艾安娜，谢谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你。这是我的荣幸。本集由劳拉·夸雷尔和帕尔斯·沙阿制作，塔拉·博伊尔和雷娜·科恩编辑。我们的团队包括托马斯·刘和珍妮·施密特。特别感谢乔纳森·伯利和乔纳斯·哈内尔的配音。我们默默无闻的英雄是阿姆斯特丹大学的理论神经心理学家约普·马拉。
Yop conducted a replication of the Herman Ebinghaus study from the 1800s, and he generously shared his time to help us understand how the first study was run. Thank you, Yop. Since this was an episode about memory, here is one thing I want you to remember. It's a website, donate.npr.org slash hidden brain. That's where you can support your local public radio station, which is the best way you can show your love for hidden brain. Again, that's donate.npr.org slash hidden brain.
约普对1800年代赫尔曼·艾宾浩斯的研究进行了重复，他慷慨地分享了他的时间来帮助我们了解第一项研究是如何进行的。谢谢你，约普。既然这是一集关于记忆的节目，这里有一件事我想让你记住。这是一个网站，donate.npr.org slash hidden brain。你可以在那里支持你的本地公共广播电台，这是你表达对《隐藏的大脑》热爱的最佳方式。再次强调，那是donate.npr.org slash hidden brain。
In case you forget it, we've posted that link on our Twitter account. Giving to your local public radio station helps make our show possible. So thank you. I'm Shankar Vedantin and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你忘记了，我们已经把那个链接发到了我们的推特账号上。向你的本地公共广播电台捐款有助于让我们的节目成为可能。所以谢谢你们。我是香卡·韦丹坦，这是NPR。你本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。